the first time we talked you said what
you would which is surreal to think that
this discussion was happening is
becoming a reality I asked you what
question would you ask an AGI system
once you create it and you said what's
outside the simulation is the question
and good question yeah but it seems like
with Gro you started to
literally uh this system's goal is to be
able to ask such questions to answer
such questions and ask such questions
where are the aliens where are the
aliens that's one of the like the FY
Paradox question um a lot of people have
asked me if I've seen any evidence of
aliens and I I haven't which is kind of
concerning because
then I think would I probably prefer at
least have seen some archaeological
evidence of aliens um to the best of my
knowledge there is no Pro I not aware of
any evidence of
alens if they're out there they're very
subtle we might just be the only
Consciousness at least in the Galaxy
um and if if you look at say the history
of earth when believe the archaeological
record Earth is about 4 and a half
billion years old civilization as
measured from the first writing is only
about 5,000 years old we have to give
some credit there to the ancient
samarians who aren't around anymore I
think it was a archaic pre uniform was
the first actual symbolic representation
but only about 5,000 years ago
I think that's a good date for when we
say civilization
started that's one millionth of Earth's
existence so civilization has been
around it's really a flash in the
panh so far
um and why why have
we why did it take so long for you know
4 and half billion
years
um for the vast majority of that time
there was no life and and then there was
archaic bacteria for a very long
time and
then you know you
had mitochondria get captured
multicellular
life um differentiation into plants and
animals life moving from the oceans to
land
mammals uh higher brain
functions and the Sun is expanding
slowly um
but it will it will overheat it will it
will heat heat the Earth up at some
point in the future um boil the oceans
and and Earth will become like Venus
where no life Life as we know it is
impossible so if we do not become
multiplanetary and
ultimately go beyond our solar system um
annihilation of all life on Earth is a
certainty a
certainty um and it could be as little
as on the galactic time
scale uh half a billion
years you know long time by human
standards but that's only 10% longer
than Earth has been around at all mhm so
if if life had taken 10% longer to
evolve on Earth it wouldn't exist at
all we got a deadline coming up better a
hurry but that said as you said humans
intelligent life on
Earth developed a lot of cool stuff very
quickly so yes it it seems like becoming
a multiplanetary is almost inevitable
unless we destroy we need to do it I
mean it's it's not I mean I suspect that
they're they're
if we are able to go out there and
explore other star systems that we
there's a good chance we find a whole
bunch of long Dead one planet
civilizations yeah they never made it
past to their home planet that's so sad
yeah sad also fascinating I mean there
are very explanations for the for me
Paradox and one is is the sort of
they're these great filters which
civilizations don't pass through and one
of those great filters is do you become
a multiplet civilization or not and if
you don't it's simply a matter of time
before something happens on your
planet um you know either natural
man-made that causes us to die out like
the
dinosaurs where are they
now that didn't have
spaceships so I think the more likely
thing is cu just a uh empathize with the
aliens that they they found us and
they're protecting us and letting us be
I hope so nice aliens just like the
tribes in the in the Amazon the on
contact tribes were protecting them
that's what uh that would be a nice
explanation or you could have like uh
what was it uh I think Andre kathi said
it's like the ants and the Amazon asking
where is
everybody well they do run into a lot of
other ants that's true these ant
Wars sounds like a good TV show yeah
they literally have these big Wars
between various
ants yeah I'm maybe I'm just
uh uh dismissing all the different
diversity events you should listen to
that W hog talking about the jungle it's
really hilarious have you heard it no I
have not but War Herzog is a
way you should play you should play it
for the you know as an interlude in the
yeah it's on YouTube it's it's
awesome I love him so much yeah uh great
was he the director of happy people life
in the tiger I think also I did that be
documentary the bar docent thing about
penguins
yeah the depr the analysis psycho
analysis of P Psy yeah the Penguin's
like headed for like mountains like that
are like 70 miles away penguin is just
headed for Doom basically well he was
had a cynical take I I have a he could
be just a brave Explorer and there'll be
great stories told about him amongst the
penguin population for many centuries to
come uh
what we talking about
okay yeah so aliens I mean I don't know
look I think the smart move uh is just
you know this is the first time in the
history of Earth that it's been possible
for life to extend beyond Earth um that
window is open um now it may be open for
a long time or it may be open for a
short
time and it it may be open now and then
never open again so I I think the smart
move here is to make life multiplanetary
while it is possible to do so we don't
want to be one of those lame One Planet
civilizations that just dies out no
those are lame
lame um self-respecting civilization
would be one planet there's not going to
be a Wikipedia entry for one of
those and uh pause uh does SpaceX have
an official uh policy for when we meet
aliens no okay that seems
irresponsible
um I mean look if I see the slightest
indication that there are aliens I will
immediately post on next platform yeah
anything I know it could be the most
liked reposted post of all time yeah I
mean look we have more satellites up
there right now than everyone else
combined so you know we'd know we know
if we've got to maneuver around
something and we're not don't have to
maneuver around
anything